images of the damage have not been
shared but the international atomic
energy agency which has monitors inside
the Ukrainian nuclear plant says a
radioactive waste and storage building
cooling Pond sprinkler system and a
cable for one of the diesel backup
generators have all been affected until
we have this plant protected the
possibility of a nuclear catastrophe is
there Rafael Grossi the director general
of the iaea told 60 Minutes the
zeparizia power plant's position on the
front lines of the war creates an
unprecedented situation for the world
Rosie has met personally with the
presidents of both Russia and Ukraine
imploring both men to create a buffer
zone around the facility the plant is
occupied by Russian forces strikes this
past weekend according to a statement
put out by the Watchdog agency came
within meters of Key Safety and Security
Systems if you protect it there's no
Dairy bomb
while the world has so far avoided a
nuclear disaster shelling around
zeparizio region has resulted in heaps
of pain
with my own eyes I saw glass flying
shrapnel flying drawers falling on me
seconds later there was a fire the gas
line erupted
says he was barefoot walking through the
debris to rescue his mother-in-law
all of this on a day of reflection in
Ukraine November 21st marks the maidan
uprising
the deadly three-month-long Civil War
started in 2013 when the government
unexpectedly ditched a European Union
agreement opting to strengthen ties with
Russia the people eventually secured new
elections constitutional reforms and got
that EU Association lighting the fuse on
the Powder Keg between the Kremlin and
Ukraine
Crystal gemancing Global News London